(audience cheering)
(audience clapping) -
[Kelly] All right. So, we talked about
how big Halloween is with your family.
So what happened?
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] How did it go this year? Oh.
- Crushed it.
- [Kelly] You crushed it.
(audience laughing)
- It was great.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- Kids went out.
- We had to split up this year.
(Kelly laughing)
That's right.
The dog. He does not have a costume on.
However later, he put
his costume on later.
He was a taco.
(audience laughing)
- [Kelly] It's like Turner and hooch
meets a basketball goal. (laughing)
- I know, I see that Turner and hooch,
the posters for that night.
- [Kelly] Oh my God I love it.
- Ugh, we really would have been great.
(Kelly laughing)
- [Kelly] Missed opportunity.
- I agree. But I was about, I
was a basketball hoop, which,
you know, my son asked me
to be a basketball hoop,
- [Kelly] Why?
- He loves Space jam.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- He was going to be bugs
bunny from Space jam,
which I then thought, great.
I'll, I'll be LeBron.
- [Kelly] We are team. Oh
(audience laughing)
- And then he said, no,
you're gonna be the hoop.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- [Kelly] He just wanted
to throw balls at you.
(Kelly laughing)
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah. That's awesome.
- And that's what happened.
And then I was like,
this is gonna be a long day.